whoa sorry vid
i'm throwing the vid out um by the way
giannis isn't here
because he is having a baby any day now
his wife's having baby any day now and
he needs to quarantine
uh because if he gets if he gets the vid
the vid from anybody that he can't be
there for the birth of his daughter yeah
he needs to be there to witness the
birth of a greek princess
he needs to be there and he also he
needs to be there to get [ __ ] on his
shoe because that's what's going to
happen in a live birth yeah
yeah is that it did you center field the
birth is that why you got [ __ ] on it
i well what happened with me with with
my daughter was
first of all the nurse said do not wear
good shoes
i was wearing like clean at the time
clean air force ones all white
and she was like honey your you know
wife's water broke she's like you're
gonna need to
uh go home and get a pair of sneakers or
if you want we could put you in
um some uh crocs she was like because
those are gonna get a little dirty i was
like boy what do you mean she was like
you'll see
yeah and then yeah she's showing up in
slicks and [ __ ]
full fishing gear big old rain slicks
dude the nurse told me i swear
the room that we were in the nurse like
they sanitized it was all like great
the woman before the woman like i guess
hours before
that gave birth in that room not only
was gave birth but also had a stomach
fire so we're spewing diarrhea
and the baby so the kid just came out
just caked and diarrhea like
yeah dude like pulling a shirt out of a
washer that's going so what happened
with us
[Music]
so some babies some babies uh they grow
nails inside the womb
so so the baby comes out yeah
so my daughter comes out we're like we
see your head and i'm like oh my god
this is so awesome they're like don't
look down don't you dare look down i'm
like i won't look down
and then i'm just waiting for like piles
of [ __ ] to fall in my shoes
and nothing and the baby's out the
baby's like all all coming out and i'm
like
well no [ __ ] and then all of a sudden i
feel i hear like
feel like fluid on my foot and i look
down and it's blood at the
at the end when the baby was being
pulled out she [ __ ] nicked
she just sticked her mom's food on on
the way i was like [ __ ] you mom
and then just bang and then they were
like they dude then they started
stitching up
my girl with no anesthesia
i was like what is going on like a civil
war fighter that's what i said
just i was like can we give her some
morphine or something do you want
somebody to come and read a prayer like
she could give her some wood to bite
down
like bite down to your teeth yeah she's
like
we're doing some frontier medicine yeah
and she's like yeah dude it's crazy
that's the
ultimate slamming the door when you
leave your mom yeah she's just
nicking the [ __ ] side picking i know
you're like [ __ ] you
you mom and you're like yeah hell no but
the her her
the the womb with the jj is so numb
from the pain of childbirth that they
can just stitch
without any anesthesia she is she didn't
feel a thing yeah she's like a prize
fighter when you know when you see them
they're like talking to the doctors and
they're just like no i'm cool
dude your head's the size of a [ __ ]
grapefruit yeah i know and then it's
funny because like
it was the most beautiful my daughter
was born ten or four in the morning
beautiful 12 15 p.m my girl's like you
got to leave like i don't want to like
you know like you're [ __ ] they get like
mad at you because they're like you put
me through this like
just get away our babies and uh you know
uh babies in the
what do you call it the um the ward the
baby ward
she's just like resting so i went and
did a table read for a show on ifc
you did blenders yeah yeah i did the
bender's ta
first table read i literally came into
the table read with still like placenta
on my shirt and steve sharipa who was
like bobby baccala from the sopranos
yeah
yeah he was like i'm you know because i
was late for the table reading jim
serpaco who's the creator and director
of the show and tom saletti we're like
oh chris he's just coming from
yeah his first child two hours ago ago
and steve was like i really had your
first kid
i was like yeah he goes hold on and he
goes to his car and he comes back with a
bottle of the sauce
he's like from my family to yours dude
congrats something new baby there's a
bottle of pomodoro steve sharip a
pomodoro sauce dude
italians italians love eating so much
that they're just like you're out okay
there we go we eat now
some sauce oh family dude they like if
you
if you could do like themes for cultures
to jerk off
like irish people would be like it would
be like irish americans would be like
about ireland right you're like
just the rolling green heroes of dublin
and they're like yeah
oh my god oh god my grandfather's from
cook oh oh god from core county off hawk
and then like italians it's like yo dude
a good
sauce and family people around you
you're like oh [ __ ] i love my family
oh god there's nothing more important
than loyalty loyalty
greece is all about [ __ ] the history
of their people they're like we were
once the greatest and they're like oh
[ __ ] yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah and then canadians are like
no thanks i'll go home
i'll go home and do that there but
that's kind of that's kind of
that's a lot thank you so much for
watching hope you enjoyed the last video
don't forget to tell your friends like
subscribe and turn on notifications